hot breath this comes from jacob
hoffpyre
hope i'm saying your name right he says
any advice for beginners that tend to
lean towards
heavyweight topics when to pull punches
when not
uh i would say don't uh i would say this
though
remember to be funny i have a
i have a friend and he's a great comic
and he wasn't getting booked and i was
talking to
the um talent guy at the just for last
festival
and uh we love uh he said we love him
but he's too caught up in the message he
forgot the funny
so if you're if you want to go
heavyweight and and i don't even know
what that means anymore
but if you want to just remember to make
it funny
and that was advice i got early on was
like a lot of people want
to be like a george carlin but it's like
first figure out how to make
the weather funny before you try to take
on like the military industrial complex
it's like just figure out how to be
funny first and then you can start to
apply that to
bigger maybe less funny topics
yeah um the the highest compliment i've
ever received in my career was being
called a spawn of carlin
that that's as good as it's ever going
to get if you if you're a topical or
social
commentary comic but um yeah you got to
learn to be funny first you got to
remember the funny because otherwise
you're preaching
in which case you could start a mega
church and make big money
man has money in that and it's all tax
free
had only i known you're too far in now
almost 30 years
there's no going back now i'm into yeah
you